[Music]
it's time now for mornings with metro uh
segment and today we're joined by
assistant sheriff andrew walsh good
morning thanks so much for being here
thanks for having us great to see you so
metro recently had a press conference
about an amazing case a 32 year old cold
case that was solved thanks to
advancements in dna testing can you walk
us through the case and talk about how
it was solved with the new technology we
got a donation from a person in the
community that
gave us enough money to actually
leverage some technology that's out
there in the private sector and through
that we were able to
use dna that had been found at a
different crime scene to locate and
identify who the murder suspect was in
that case
he is also deceased at this point so
there'll be no criminal case following
it but something like that's really
important it highlights several things
one is obviously our commitment to
investigating and solving murders and
violent crime no matter how old they are
but also it brings a bit of closure to
that family as well to you know they
finally know what happened and who did
it absolutely
let's talk about a lot of cases seems
like we've seen more this year this
summer of pets left in hot cars hot
garages and some of those pets didn't
survive
what is metro doing in these cases uh
when what kind of
charges do people face in these
situations and
i mean sometimes these people these uh
dogs are suffering and needlessly so
what happens to that you know the
temperature inside of a vehicle can get
upwards of 140 degrees and you know it's
it's it's really sad because we do
enough media on these things we do
enough
advertising of haiti
yeah it's it's year in year out and this
year we have
a slightly a little over 20 i think it's
23 cases where we file criminal charges
and those charges can
range from uh felonies to uh there's one
felony charge for torturing and uh
abusing an animal to there's a
misdemeanor charge so the charges will
vary depending upon the
the length of time and the severity of
the injuries to the animals and it's
very unfortunate well kids are back to
school this week
there was a press conference with ccsd
police and metro what is being done to
keep the kids safe they're trying to get
readjusted back to the classroom at the
first week during the first week of
school we set up a command post to make
sure that that week goes smooth and
that's the week we typically see people
come back together for the first time
especially now it's been it could be an
extended period of time before people
have seen each other so we make sure
that that goes smooth but then
throughout the year all the
different things that go on with the
different
threats that come in hey i heard this
rumor that there's going to be a fight i
heard this rumor there's going to be you
know a violent
event in a park after school all that
stuff comes into our fusion center and
there's a mechanism where it's reported
through the state as well uh and that's
coordinated through the fusion center
the southern nevada counterterrorism
center and that coordinates the response
and it coordinates what the uh who the
appropriate jurisdiction is to follow up
on that so it really is a joint effort
uh even though the school district has
their own police department
the force multiplier is all the other
police departments in in our
jurisdiction
thank you assistant sheriff andrew walsh
appreciate you being here as always
mornings with metro it's one of our best
segments we appreciate you thanks for
having me thank you